ils ont entre 12 et 17 ans et tous le
même rêve devenir footballeur
professionnel
david miliband 14 ans entame sa
troisième année à l'école de foot des
brasseries du cameroun en 2019 il a été
sélectionné parmi 5000 jeunes venus de
tout le pays une première étape pour lui
permettre de toucher du doigt son rêve
des informations avaient un contrat
professionnel est allé dans les autres
créé en 1989
l'école de foot des brasseries du
cameroun est la plus ancienne académie
du pays elle est devenue une référence
en la matière et beaucoup de grands
joueurs ont fait leurs débuts ici
rigobert song geremi n'jitap samuel
eto'o mais aussi d'actuels lions
indomptables comme vincent aboubakar
pour marcher dans leurs pas les soixante
six apprentis footballeurs sont soumis à
un rythme intensif école le matin
entraînement l'après-midi soutien
scolaire le soir
sans oublier les matches tous les week
end ils sont suivis sur six ans par une
douzaine d'entraîneurs diplômés j'ai été
formé c'est après bon j'ai pas eu la
chance d'être footballeur professionnel
je connais mes chutes je connais les
manquements et aujourd'hui j'ai fait de
les amener à a grandi à fès les choses
que nous on n'a pas pu faire chaque
année 11 joueurs sortent de l'école la
promotion 2022 est particulièrement
prometteuse c'est à peu près tous les
dix ans qu'une accalmie comme la nôtre
sort en grand un grand talent a donc
naturellement on a eu des passages à
vide où on avait des talents moyens et
cette année on a deux joueurs qui vont
aller respectivement à à lille et à
marseille dont ce qui est quand même des
taux de transfert tous les stagiaires
n'auront pas la chance de jouer à haut
niveau
n'épargne eux se trouve peut-être la
prochaine étoile du football camerounais